on this episode we tackle is reddit sold
out already embedded Facebook videos on
your website and how do I build a
digital team inside of my print and TV
agency you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 87 of the askgaryvee
show before I get into the show I want
to give a huge shout out to all the
vaynernation that's watching live on
meerkat right now and who jumped in and
gave a little sherry share share to the
video I just put out on Facebook let's
can we we can link it in the comments on
YouTube we can't put it up here because
it has to be on garyvaynerchuk.com
correct correct but linked in the
YouTube I know a lot of podcast
listeners are listening so if you jump
in and you go to facebook.com slash Gary
a video I just put up a little bit ago
an original video we've been making
these videos d-roc Stefan the whole
video team has been crushing for me I'm
really proud of this one it speaks to my
essence the inception music is exciting
and and most of all I just I just am
really grateful for the vayniacs the
vaynernation that just did that for me
big share up little little right hook on
meerkat before the show so thank you
and now let's uh let's get into the show
all right as we get into the show first
of all show stunwin who you know has has
has been a rare appearance lately it's
been very very very much the india show
here but it's good to have you in the
house mr. stylman about your roots roots
baby Ruths
you said like Eric a star when Mach
became a celebrity on Wine Library TV
that's for your old school vayniacs
alright well I crush it up here Tim
let's get the show Maui gagging Luis
asks where would you start in building a
digital team within a traditional TV or
print agency Louis I there's an
interesting thing that I believe in very
much which is you are what your actions
show you are it's very similar you know
I'm probably affected by Bill Parcells
in football legendary Hall of Fame coach
Bill Parcells former jet coach oh he
said you are what your record says you
are because you know everyone's like oh
we're 88 but we could have been 10 and
six if we you know at the end of day you
are what you are
thanks Mike and so you know it's very
easy to create a digital practice within
a traditional parental direct-mail
outdoor media
Oh PR all these agencies now have to
shift into the world that we've created
because that's where the dollars and the
momentum and where the storytelling is
going you know this video will be
consumed the hell of a lot more in
YouTube native video like she's mean
YouTube and Facebook native then it will
as a pre-roll pop up somewhere and so I
think it's super important that um that
you understand you are what your actions
say you are meaning it's very easy go
out and hire seven to twelve people that
work in digital social bring them into
your department and now you have that
capability
now the key for the CEO the chairman of
the board her and his job is to really
integrate that new you know we're going
through it now vaynermedia has a new
live division called Vayner live it's
live events activation it's not what
we've historically done it's activating
at Coachella or South by or things of
that nature and we're six months in we
still have to integrate it into the
business but we brought in Robert and
other people that have done that work in
the past now we have the skill set now
how does that practice mold into the
whole organization that's the tricky
part
that's where dictatorship comes in
that's where letting things happen the
way they have to happen I'm a big fan of
letting things lie so I've stayed
hands-off for the first several six half
months now maybe I feel like maybe I'll
get my hands in a little bit dirtier
just get it molded in but you know
leadership is knowing when to listen
knowing when to talk no one want to take
a step back knowing when to jump in and
integrate it but the commodity of hiring
people that have the skill set to do the
work it's out there it's just making the
leap to decide to do it Andrew asks do
you plan on your betting Facebook videos
on your website instead of YouTube
videos and is it more beneficial to do
so if you're not monetizing and drop a
big fan of Facebook video and the whole
rant here early on I mean we put it up
on YouTube
and I clearly just threw my right hook
to Facebook that look a funny thing
about me is my actions always speak to
where my strategy is so that's an
interesting insight I care less about
the perception of having twenty fifty a
hundred thousand views on YouTube than I
do about getting the Facebook virality
that that ecosystem creates I'm a big
fan of it because the truth is the
virality that facebook allows you I
think is greater
than the virality that YouTube allows
you and I think when you're not
monetizing you know virality the ability
for it to get shared and new people to
see it I mean the vaynernation just
helped me so much and I ask for even
more I want people to see this because
it's I believe it's a good piece of
content for me to be a first look at me
because it's really an essence of Who I
am it's a good first look it's a good
first impression for me it's also very
well produced I'm interested in people
seeing it and I and right now you you
know Facebook feels like the right place
to send those people so yes I would be
and I recommend and I think you should
everybody should be very serious about
embedding Facebook videos into their
pages in lieu of YouTube at least for
nothing else than context you may want
to go back to YouTube for whatever
rationale because it's a very important
and very powerful platform as well you
may be going into the new subscription
product they have maybe a million
different things and reasons to do it
but here's what I don't stand you know
what you're getting from YouTube from
last decade by not tasting what Facebook
could be bringing to you is just a
mistake in overall strategy between any
of these wines help me Lori
first of all thank you so much for the
question big shout out to all the sharks
that I've been mingling with the sharks
lately look Lori I think everybody has
this problem I think that buying wine
when you're trying to figure it out
you're not gonna be able to make a
judgement on the label buying wine based
on the label crushes my soul buying wine
because the Shelf talker says 90 points
is the secondary move that crushes my
soul though Wine Library does that at
scale and we put up those shelf dollars
because it sells wine I think the best
thing you can do is form a relationship
with your wine person and have them
really learn your palette over time
that's gonna work for you 70 80 percent
of time because you're not always gonna
be by your local wine shop or that
person might be sick that day that uh I
think the the best move in lieu of the
wine person is to try a different
varietal every time you go by
recognizing that trying a Gewurztraminer
or a Marcin or a ruse on or
the rack or uh or a lunar belt leaner or
alle grind try you know corn Oz trying
these different things right
blough frappe gosh like just trying new
stuff it's always a great way to go
you're scared that you're gonna try
something you don't like but again it's
really no different than the advice I
just gave about Facebook video when you
haven't tried something you can't judge
it got it and so the value of trying
something and creating the context
content miss King context is God
something I love to say this is another
version of it you've got to try new
stuff so build a relationship Steve you
know my palate what do you got today Oh
weird you know you're recommending a
pinot taj from south africa cool I'll
try it but no Steve he's sick today try
some I've never had you know anything
from Lodi before or I've disregarded
buttery Chardonnay is for five years let
me try another one just to see where my
palate is and where those shards are in
California these days so mix it up
Rodolfo asks do you have a business card
if so can we see it but Dolph oh I do
not have a business card a business card
in 2015 makes absolutely zero sense a
business card delivers information take
out your phone and email the person on
the spot better cleaner never lose the
business card more efficient it's right
you should I like to show them is this
your email good good good like Alex asks
will reddit be ruined by future
marketers if so how Alex everything gets
ruined by marketers because marketers
want to make money
original audiences feel it's ruin look
money will let it be ruined by marketers
you know that's like asking you know
when you're indie band becomes big did
they sell out some say yes some say no
it's really eyes of the beholder I'm
sure there's people Steve you love
reddit go to Steve let's go Steve Steve
you love reddit I do you know there's
clearly
more there's it's more commercial than
it was seven or eight years ago say it's
already been ruined thank you where do
you sit on that I don't think so at all
okay but you feel like people that are
even more cynical and extreme than you
have exist yes right and since it right
I mean like you know I'm optimist than a
commerce salesman Steve is more cynical
but like more down the line like
creating friction and there are some
people that are completely out of their
goddamn mind that ii read it makes one
cent
that in itself signifies that it's sold
out and by the way I respect that
because I'm the extreme I look at
everything until it makes money I'm like
that sold out the other way right like
that's too pure you know like so I think
that um it's I of the beholder
I think Facebook is less sold out today
than it was twenty six months ago
because I think their algorithms better
think about that twenty six months later
and that's an arbitrary number 2428 I
don't even know how I came up that
twenty six months later Facebook is
doing a better job putting stuff in
people speed that makes it feel less
commercial than it did before because
the algorithm is getting better
to me that's wild that's what I mean
it's better for me like taking like
personal me its queasy to me they've
done a good job so Evan flow read it may
do a takeover thing next week with Taco
Bell that often seems like I was wrong
when we clean it so up like it just evan
flows but look marketers and business
people's jobs are to make money that
will always go against the friction of
people that want to keep things artistic
and pure it's a good friction point I
think the people that a really special
attic can walk them in those aligned you
think of an apple you think of a Nike
you think of a reddit I'm fascinated by
that I listen if something I try to keep
and I think I skew a little bit more
towards commerce and sellout then I do
then artists but that's because I talk
about the subject matter of business and
I think one of the reasons I'm lucky
enough to have an audience is I'm in the
jabs business you know the right hooks
are coming and as long as I'm providing
way more jabs than right hooks the
balance of the force
Chewbacca style is in good shape so
that's a scoop that's the show question
of the day is a right hook I want you to
watch this goddamn video and I want you
to leave a comment on it you
asking questions I'll keep answering
them hey everyone so here is the meerkat
right hook I just post this video and I
tweeted it so I just posted it on my
Facebook page let's make sure that is up
there just want to go facebook.com slash
Gary yes there it is you're seeing it
all right
and I just tweeted it Casey nice that
gave me some love on it that was very
nice you saw that it just gave some love
oh yeah so it's on Twitter it's on
Facebook what I want to understand is is
the vaynernation willing to right now go
to the video and hit the share button
right because that's really interesting
to me right now it's a forty-nine
because I want to create instant
virality little right hook action out of
gamification meerkat action here right
so r53 who is willing to give me a yes
or no who is willing to go and give me a
share right now on the facebook video
who's in who's in I'm gonna have to now
wait wait and wait no you're go yes
absolutely Sean thank you so much video
feed down what is he saying oh the video
feed is down my video feed up your cat I
don't think so my Wi-Fi is on I'm good
yes yes yes hang on I'm gonna go do it
thank you so much Cody thank you so much
Keith thank you so much up Brett Perry
thank you so much too late I already did
it Thank You Dungey oh this gonna be fun
to watch let's watch this together 62
you got a 62 let me get my refresh this
is fun I got 67 71
I got 72 do you rock loves 100 I called
him Dave because I got excited
76 vaynernation thank you so much it
would mean so much oh yeah there's a
fresh cut thank you
it would mean so much to me if you guys
can pass on this video I think who did
this you Stefan who did it you didn't
you rock so let's show you
we're always working together than it
but but this was but uh I thought this
was a really good one I'm really I'm
really personally excited about this one
because it's one of the first times ever
ever
my dad is starring I want to show them
that my dad Sasha here it is Brandon
John Kay it's good the fact that I've
been working 19 hours a day every day
for the last 20 years thank you guys so
much ice appreciate it I'll skim to show
I'll give you a follow on the Graham hit
me up on Twitter if you want me to do
things setting me up on Twitter is
usually a really good way to go about it
so cool I appreciate it i preciate you
absorbing my right hook vaynernation and
honestly this video means a lot to me so
anything you can do the shares huge but
whether it's Twitter or email
newsletters your blog post I want to get
this out there the link to the Facebook
means a lot to me I'm curious by the
virality of the share units so thank you
so much
alright now given to you Stefan let's
get into show where's India not feeling
well all right there I'm just taking one
more look 127 so fun what's the update
on their shares we're at a hundred and
ninety seconds
let's go vinter nation get everybody in
get on gchat tex friends let's go
where's Tyler let's go